tomb raider it opens Thursday March the
15th you are the new Lara Croft and
obviously not like Tonya Harding you're
not a real person
but people have such a clear vision of
who this woman is I must be the kind of
similar pressure yeah my breasts are not
as pointy as the first no I mean yeah
she's been with us for like what I said
20 22 years and and I yeah I I actually
I was you know we grew up with Emerson
yeah things I also grew up in a time
where there was none of my girlfriends
who played video games and I kind of
kept it you know I was kind of ashamed
of doing it but I was at my my parents
friend friend's house and their kids had
a Playstation and I went there and I
remember I walked into the room I saw it
it was a female protagonist in a video
game and I'd never seen that and yeah I
was a bit too scared to play the whole
game when I was about ten so I mostly
spent the time kind of doing the tricks
and her learning her moves and the
manner but no I've been yeah I was a big
fan when I was Daniel are you a big
gamer did you do play a little games no
because it ruins my life realized that
now when I did it they did play the
games before I did the film and I was
like wow I had way too much time when I
was a child what did you have to train
for that so I did about four months
before I started to shoot when I got
into I was like really
yes so that's the thing it takes I'm
talking four months for me I'd never
lifted a thing with my arms I didn't my
story
[Laughter]
so it takes about four months to you
know I remember that my trainer told him
is that's their really underdeveloped
okay and then but then four months later
you know he managed I told him I don't
believe you but yeah it is not then it
takes three weeks for you to lose it all
yeah that is the sad crazy I know
because you're Swedish how does that
work cause obviously you're married to
an Irishman now so so are you learning
Irish are you learning Irish phrases I
was just actually quite close a lot of
people think that I'm Irish because in
Sweden I guess we have the same arse
mm-hmm yeah this is a bit of a
connection there and it's new learning
Swedish phrases I wish it was better
actually one thing that he likes is he
came to Sweden and he learned that it's
a lot of we have a lot of Swedish
sayings that are very commonly used and
it's one of those things when it's my
own language I didn't really think about
how weird they are but he learned about
them and he was like I'm just now gonna
use those and it's like saying in
Swedish well now you're taking a poop in
the blue cabinet yeah it's like a very
common thing or like yeah you can't just
expect yourself you know to walk in here
like sliding in on a shrimp sandwich
it's all politicians when I was back
home round Sweden
used that in a debate in Swedish I was
like yeah that's how you can't come in
here and slide on a shrimp sandwich you
know in an in a socialist country having
a shrimp son which is very fancy so it's
like you conscious have your privileges
and walk in slide in here on a shrimp
sandwich we have an Australian one we're
not here to [ __ ] spiders it'd be
difficult
you